[Musique]
ce château est entourée de toutes sortes
le genre de rêve
et ce château représente justement cette
côté fantastique cette côte est
inhabituelle de ses châteaux parce qu'on
voit ici on voit dans l'arche cette dame
blanche malheureuse femme belle femme on
voit aussi
ses châteaux de beauce ont tous les
deux coloris froide notre devoir c'est
un château fort a
roy ici cette visage magnifique c'est
l'actuel là-bas parce que château devos
est toujours hanté par des fantômes
ils parlent de femmes vivant qu'elles
sont dépensés sans limites pour ford à
reste magnifique monument historique
[Musique]
citadelle construite en 808 quand
charlemagne forme le royaume d'aquitaine
ce n'est qu'en 1080 que les titres latin
atteste l'existence du château en
possession du chevalier arnaud devos
partiellement démoli sous richelieu qui
voyaient d'un mauvais oeil cette place
forte levée contre le centralisme et
l'autorité royale le château fut dès
lors maintes fois reconstruit et
transformer ces constructions
irrégulières lui donne aujourd'hui un
aspect hardy et pittoresque gigantesque
et charmant hanté par l'histoire et par
les fantômes cette partie s'appelle
passage des soldats
les chroniques et l'ancien chroniqueur
explique les soldats y sont ici sont pas
si courantes un peu dans la nuit et dans
la journée après la nuit son domicile
recense deux dortoirs c'est charles
pendant 10 12e siècle rien n'a changé
si c'est contre le poteau on pendait les
gens pendant la révolution
[Musique]
c'est ici notamment que l'uci est morte
elle est mort plutôt dans ce tour ils
partirent un peu plus vaste danser tout
l'été et mirella rester ici jusqu'aux
derniers jours de sa vie à sept tours
marois fait
[Musique]
jour à 12 h salle des gars là toda du
12e siècle sont en hausse masque
impeccablement savait très vieux 17,95
alors ce sera le cas selon la légende
l'éléphante on se promène en tout la
liberté on voit cette fabiola c'est à
dire une autre femme semble aussi se
font du château voilées attendait
tom lee en quoi la faune du château avec
escalier vous l'avez vu lui si
c'est à dire on pense toujours est
quelqu'un qui pas pour ce sujet une
impression qui est la cause la relation
la bête ce sujet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
bien mais c'est le châtelain vous
travaillez beaucoup vous travaillez
souvent dans cette bibliothèque
pas tellement mèche et dernièrement
presque chaque soir avant cette appli
rare mais quand vous savez très bien
j'ai beaucoup à faire je peux pas me
permettre aux gens le soir et que je
suis tout seul et qu'on ne peut pas
aller achats ce qui aussi je suis mal
footing le
silence de ce château mais inspire comme
ça je commence à travailler des articles
militaires des articles sur le château
une nouvelle fantastique que le
châtelain écrit beaucoup ils composent
même une histoire de l'auvergne avec une
thèse nouvelle et révolutionnaire
vous avez quand même une thèse tout à
fait personnel qui consiste à dire que
beaucoup du dernier à décembre de juifs
auraient presque effet ils descendent
âge ils ont compliqué la famille comme
par exemple la famille de bana et les
autres comme la mienne de boire aussi sa
touche l'ancien juge mais ça ne plaît
pas beaucoup yahoo vergnas érosif
[Musique]
e
j'ai commencé ma carrière dans la vie
comme dans la cavalerie mais je trouvais
que c'était
assez triste je serais quelque excuse
valable
parce que ça que je me confonds rien
toujours je suis maintenant si les
belges géante à l'école polytechnique
je suis sentie comme ingénieur ces
critères mais vi il s'appelle el genia
de prendre des chances et
fils du baron board d'ordinaire
conseillait la cour impériale d'autriche
ephraim francs soit à gori de la tour a
bien derrière lui un passé exceptionnel
il fait ses études à tel-aviv moscou et
varsovie sa carrière militaire le mène
en mandchourie en espagne en pologne en
union soviétique comme officier il y
reçoit les félicitations personnel de
staline et c'est là qu'il rencontrera de
gaulle
204 aujourd'hui quand je rencontrais à
mouscou l'époque il est venu très tôt
beaucoup à faire aussi et maltais aussi
soviétique était très
surpris je vous parlais je rendis
quelques services il me qu'il est dense
desquels il me dit que la france
n'oublie pas jamais service que je rends
dit que c'est la france a oublié elle
s'agite
conseillers militaires de l'état major
en israël puis ingénieur conseil à paris
à gori de la tourner a reçu pas moins de
seize décorations et citations croix
d'or des braves croix d'or du mérite
l'ordre d'union soviétique des médailles
pour la défense de moscou stalingrad
varsovie pour la prise de berlin un
passé prestigieux que sa vie
d'exploitants agricoles et d'éleveurs de
chevaux depuis
1971 ne laisse aucunement transparaître
la vie de châtelain finalement c'est un
peu fou j'avais les ans ce fou premier
rachat est devenue objet de la centrale
et après
des commencements tout le monde synthèse
beaucoup on vient voir château cette
magnifique construction mais on voit
aussi c'est ici cette ville l'ong
séduire cette vie dame toujours
solitaires
sans domestique difficulté
si
le type marginal la cuisine est mauvaise
y'a pas beaucoup spécialité 1 d'aspa
bouki blues ou le château en principe
c'est long c'est louis christ une dame
sera encore plus pire c'est une dame
très méfiante tout fout l'camp il a en
vérité un châtain est toujours celle
exposée dans toute la difficulté de sa
vie quotidienne
cible de la politique parce que c'est
infernal et aussi
[Musique]
mais aussi l'ont perdu qu'attendent tout
cela ensemble je préfère rester dans ma
solitude dans la profonde solitude avec
mes bêtes avec ma chienne
avec neuf immeubles
avec ma mauvaise cuisine
comme à l'est
se frotter avec des milliers de
personnes dans les rues de paris ou dans
l'autre
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]